hey what is up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 8 of game programming
ok so last time we talked about buffered
image and pixels and how I'm how you
know would get the raster to actually
upload pixel data to our buffer and in
turn displayed on to the screen so we
didn't actually change anything we still
had this black screen so what we're
going to do today is actually talk about
how we are going to manipulate those
pixels so we've created a way to
actually write to those pixels but how
we going to write to them and that's
what we're going to cover today so first
thing I want to do is actually create a
new class so over here on our rein
folder I'm going to right-click hit new
and click class and I'll just name it
screen now I usually call this class
screen and essentially what it is is our
screen it's our class that actually
displays our pixels that's all it does
it just fills pixels in with colors that
we specify so my name is screen you'll
also name it render I'll call it random
in the past as well I'm calling a screen
hit finish and this new class is going
to have a few different
things first of all it's going to
actually have a width and a height so
private int width and we're not going to
add anything to it and we also want
private int high
now instead of typing it out on two
lines because you can see that they are
both private integers we could just get
rid of this and put a comma dividing
them and create them on one line so
we're creating two variables on one line
and again the name the names that we're
specifying are being divided by this
comma now we're not going to we're
actually going to set values to them
because we don't need to at the moment
the other thing that I'm going to do is
actually create a public int and this is
going to be an array and I'll just call
it pixels and I'm not I'm not actually
going to set anything to that as well
what I'm creating it yet so these two
things there's going to be the width and
the height of our screen and then this
is going to be the array that contains
all of our pixel data what I want to do
what I want to do now is actually create
a constructor for them so public screen
and it's going to take two parameters
width and height both integers are not
splain all this in a minute don't worry
and what I'm simply going to say here is
that did this dot width equals width and
this dot height equals high okay so what
are we doing here what we're doing here
is if we go back to our game class and
actually create this screen object so
right under running I'm just going to
type private screen screen and again
we're referring to our screen object and
actually what I want to do is actually
put that into a new pathogen but I'm
actually going to put it into a sub
package or a subfolder called graphics
so if I just named graphics here in the
package and then actually you know move
screen to that declaration you'll see
that we've got a new folder here called
graphics and this folder is going to
contain all our classes that actually
deal with graphics and stuff like that
and if I go here you'll see that it
doesn't know where swear screen is so we
actually have to import it because it's
in a different package than the game
class
so we'll import that and if we go over
here when we want to create it and hit
up screen equals new screen oops
and we'll actually do this above the
jframe right right over here we actually
need to enter parameters into it and the
only things that we're going to enter is
the width and height so we'll simply
type width and height and again it's
refers to this within this hype' so
what's happening here essentially is
we're creating a new instance of screen
right a new screen object and this top
width equals width means that it's
actually going to make this width over
here equal to our parameter equal to
whatever we put over here
whatever whatever we put over here and
same with height it's going to make this
height in this in this screen class
equal to this height which is this
height so it's making width equal 300
and height equal width divided by 16
times 9 the other thing we'll do is
we'll actually create the pixel all
right now so we'll just type pixels
equals new int and width times height
okay so that's all that's all we're
doing okay to sum up this episode
because I've got so much work over this
weekend that I'm just not having time at
all for this what we've done today is
we've created a screen class and we've
actually instantiated that screen class
as you can see we've set it equal to new
screen we've created a new instance of a
screen we've created a screen for
ourselves and we've applied
we've applied the size of our screen to
these two variables so that we can now
actually deal with it with with these
variables in our actual screen class and
then tomorrow when we actually go onto
rendering things by using pixels you'll
um you'll be able to see how that works
but what we've also done is we've
created an array of pixels an array an
array of integers which is the size of
width times height so in other words
we've created one integer for each pixel
in our game okay we've created one
integer for each pixel that is in our in
our screen and again so yeah tomorrow
we'll move on to actually drawing the
pixels onto the screen the individual
pixels onto the screen and we'll see if
we can create something cool just to
demonstrate the the power of this power
of this game engine so yeah I'm sure I'm
sorry for the short up side guys but I
gotta go so yeah hope you liked the
video if you did please hit the like
button it allows me know that you guys
are actually enjoying this you know and
I'll see you guys tomorrow bye
[Music]